[Musique]
l'an dernier aucune fille ne suivait une
formation dans ce centre cette année
elles sont sept
la majorité d'entre elles préparent un c
ap peinture comme justin et anaïs leur
point commun une assurance à toute
épreuve c'est vrai que c'est un défi
quand même parce que bon les quarts
seront pas très facile il faut faire ses
preuves comme je vous ai dit il faut
montrer qu'on a du caractère faut pas se
laisser marcher sur les pieds
faire évoluer les mentalités n'est pas
évident comme partout ce cfa pratique
l'alternance et lorsqu'elles ont dû
partir à la recherche d'une entreprise
les portes sont souvent restées closes
j'ai eu beaucoup de noms des réponses
négatives si on a eu beaucoup et
quelques-unes parfois oui mais trop loin
que moi donc souvent disent non et re
cherche pas d'apprentis ou noël ont déjà
quelqu'un on se bat na le prenait dans
le bon sens quoi je me disais il faut
que je continue
puis j'ai continué enfin on m'a aidé
aussi élevé dans un milieu fortement
masculin toutes ces jeunes femmes n'ont
en tout cas pas baisser les bras pour
parvenir à leur but
le cas de leurs marchands inscrits en
travaux publics est encore plus
significatif
elle est également engagée pour l'armée
en tant que réserviste
je trouve tout le temps quelque chose à
faire au niveau de l'armée c'est aussi
un un projet peut-être par l'avenir est
à lier les deux donc travailler dans
l'armée mais dans le btp bague au doigt
et au mieux elle est trop que ça
maintenant parce qu'il faut rien déçu ce
camp situé d'une liste
ce sont des pistes quand on sait
travailler on peut trouver le but c'est
moins pour moi c'est je le trouvais dans
n'importe quelle entreprise tant qu'on
sait travailler on aura toujours quelque
chose par derrière
on aura toujours le boulot donc que ce
soit un homme ou une femme c'est
toujours la même chose qui est cet
engouement féminin pour les métiers
traditionnellement réservé aux hommes
pourraient permettre de mettre fin à la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre dans le btp
chaque année il manque encore entre 700
et 1000 apprentis dans les yvelines
[Musique]
l'égalité hommes femmes en politique un
objectif affiché par le gouvernement
mais loin d'être atteints aux français
dans les yvelines depuis 2013
l'obligation de listes paritaires aux
municipales a été élargie à toutes les
communes de plus de 1000 habitants
bilan 16 mille conseillère municipale
supplémentaires devraient être élus mais
le nombre de femmes mères risque lui de
ne pas beaucoup évoluer
actuellement nous avons un peu plus de
16% de deux femmes mères par les et
blessures les 262 communes
donc la situation est meilleure que
furent niveau national des données assez
faible or selon un sondage ifop de début
mars
70% des français souhaiteraient qu'ils
aient plus de femmes air notamment parce
qu'ils pensent qu'elle ferait de la
politique autrement plus honnête et plus
à l'écouté des habitants pour 82% des
sondés
mais c'est vrai qu'être maire et
présidente d'une interco pour les femmes
je pense que c'est bien moi je rencontre
beaucoup de plaisir oise qui me disant
mais on est très content que ce soit une
femme l'écouté différentes
vous n'êtes plus ce peut-être en
ouverture c'est évident une femme mais
souvent plus maternante entre guillemets
mais ça n'empêche pas que je sois ferme
et bien décidé qu est-ce qui explique
alors que les femmes soient relégués au
poste de conseillère municipale plutôt
qu'à celui de maire les candidats avance
deux raisons majeures le manque de
renouvellement des élus mais aussi une
certaine forme d'autocensure on voit que
les hommes n'aiment pas trop laisser
leur place à plus de suppléante que de
femmes députées même incertain certains
postes même aux sénatoriales etc
en tête de liste après je pense que les
femmes sont peut-être plus plus longue à
prendre des décisions allaient nous
sommes sûrs et le renouvellement prendra
donc du temps mais les lois en faveur de
la parité et les jeunes générations
devrait faire évoluer les choses
l'association elle aussi propose
quelques outils pour aller dans ce sens
par exemple un guide de l'élu pour
inciter les femmes à s'engager et
expliquer les acquis au niveau
professionnel
[Musique]